It's interesting that young white men are only 10% of the population, but 98% of the military deaths.
You ask for a stat check and you'll get one.
When you break it down by race, black Americans were actually more likely to die in pretty much every recent war.
For instance, in the Vietnam conflict, black men made up 12.4% of all American deaths.
However, black Americans only made up around 10% of the population.
And this is also true for deaths since 1980.
If you want those stats, you can look them up at the DCAS.
So the claim in that video that young white men make up 90% of the military deaths is false.
And since that video was about privilege, I'm going to go ahead and talk about that.
Looking up USA facts, how many people do you think died in the military in 2022?
The answer is 844 deaths out of all of the armed forces in 2022.
In a total of zero of those deaths were from hostile action or terrorist attacks.
The largest numbers were self-inflicted, accidents, illness, pending, and homicide.
I went ahead and grabbed how many people are a part of the military.
And long story short, if we're just including the active duty military members,
then the death rate is about 65.6 per 100,000 people.
In 2021, black women have had the highest maternal mortality rate in the United States
at 69.9 out of every 100,000 live births.
That means it was actually more dangerous in 2021 for a black woman to give birth.
And it was for the average person to be active duty in the military in 2022.
So for this stat check, I'm going to have to rate that claim completely false.
Thanks for the tag, I'll try to do it as often as I can.